في مخيم جباليا في منطقه نادي الخدمات
قامت طائرات الاحتلال قبل قليل باستهداف
عدد من المنازل في هذا المكان هناك عدد
كبير من الشهداء
والاصابات عدد من المنازل كما نشاهد دمرت
في هذا المكان هناك محاوله
البحث يا
شباب
يا
عم
وينيه يطلع طنا
انسس تعال انس
جوهد هنا انس حجم الدمار في المكان كبير
جدا كلها نازحين ايش صار بالط كل العماره
نازحين ثلاث دور ثلاث دور نازحين نزلت
عليهم زي ما انت شايف مربع كامل راح كله
كله اطفال تحت افال مش قادرين نطلع
حدا صغار مش قادرين نطلعهم تحت شا
صورس معسكر جبال في مخيم جبال حسب الله
ونعم الوكيل حسب الله ونعم الوكيل طبعا
مشاهد هذه المشاهد المباشره بعد ارتكاب
الاحتلال لمجزره جديده بحق المواطنين
الابرياء بعد استهدافه عدد من المنازل
بجانب نادي خدمات
جباليا طبعا هذه المنطقه مقتض
بالسكان ن نقترب نقترب اكثر نحاول الدخول
هنا
راحتك
الكيلز دار الجنب دار عزام و دار قفه وع
دار بكنا شهداء الحمد لله شهاده نيال
الشهيد عند ربه نال الشهيد عند ربه يمكن
اك من 200 نفق عماد عماد كلهم هنا حجم هذا
الدمار كبير جدا في المكان المكان مقتض
بالسكان ايضا في هذه البيوت يوجد عدد من
النازحين هنا النيران مازالت مشعله في
المكان مربع كامل دمر في هذه
المنطقه حجم الدمار في هذا المكان كبير
جدا
طبعا هذه المنطقه تضم الاف
السكان في مخيم جباليا ايضا هذه المنازل
يوجد بها عدد من النازحين عدد الشهداء
كبير والاصابات وايضا
المفقودين طبعا نذهب الى الاتجاه الاخر من
هذه المنطقه طبعا هنا المواطنين يحاولون
البحث عن بعض المفقودين في المكان ايضا
الطواقم الطبيه والدفاع المدني تحاول
الوصول لهذه
الاعداد هنا اكثر هنا الدفاع المدني يحاول
البحث عن عدد كبير من المفقودين في
المكان هنا نحن بجانب نادي خدمات
جباليا تم تدمير مربع سكني
بالكامل طبعا هنا ما زالت النيران مشتعله
في
المكان كما نشاهد هناك اضرار ايضا في
المنازل
[موسيقى]
المجاوره هي راسه جاي
لهيك كما نشاهد هنا طواقم الدفاع المدني
تحاول الوصول لاحد المواطنين من تحت
الانقاض يحاولون بايديهم بمعداتهم
البسيطه من الوصول لبعض
المفقودين كما تحدثنا في
السابق هذا المكان مكتظ بالسكان عدد
الشهداء كبير جدا في المكان والاصابات
ايضا والمفقودين هنا المنازل ممتلئه
بالمواطنين طبعا هناك صعوبه في وصول الى
المفقودين تحت الركام بسبب الامكانيات
البسيطه والمعدات البسيطه مع طواقم الدفاع
[موسيقى]
المدني الله اكبر الله
اكبر
عايش
عايش طبعا هنا انتشال احد المواطنين من
تحت
الركام
يا حبيبي
قومي لسانه طبعا هنا انتشال احد المواطنين
من تحت
الركام طبعا طفل كما
تشاهدون هذا الطفل الان تم انتشاله من
المكان طبعا هناك
انتشال انتشال ايضا لاحد
المواطنين هناك اعداد كبيره من المفقودين
تحت
الرك طبعا هنا ايضا في الخلف مازالوا
يبحثون عن
مفقودين نقترب اكثر
المكان طبعا هنا المواطنون حبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل يحاولون الوصول مازالوا لبعض
المفقودين متاكد ابوك
قول
ش هنا المواطنين بجانب طواقم الدفاع
المدني مازالوا يبحثون عن عدد كبير من
المفقودين تحت ركام هذه
المنازل المكان هنا مدمر
بالكامل طبعا هذه المجزره ارتكبها
الاحتلال بحق المواطنين الابرياء
[موسيقى]
الامنين لا
يمكن احصاء عدد الشهداء او الاصابات او
المفقودين ايضا في هذا المكان مش عارفين
عن
عصور
للع امنه في محلها وقت عشاء وقت ليل كل
بيت عنده 70 انا عندي 50 نفر في الدار
بدون سابق انذار اقسم بالله العظيم انا
سابع تامن دار ساكن وراي مذبحه مجزره
الناس فوق بعض حوالي مربع كامل مش هيك ناس
امنين ناس عند بيوتها وين الروح وين اروح
وين نروح اكثر من هيك احنا نزحنا والناس
نزحت عنا واحنا اجينا اكثر من هيك شسوي
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل انا بعرفه انا بعرفه كويس سكين في
50 نفر والبيت اللي ورا 30 والبيت اللي
هنا الناس طوابق ساكين 20 نفر و40 نفر
والبيت اللي وراه واللي جنبه ودار درابيه
جيراننا كل الناس انت بتحكي عن سبع دور
مدادك بالكامل الناس نايمه الصغار نايمين
الصغ والعجايز والكبار ولحتى الان الساعه
شهدا تحت الارض تحت الارض ماوصل لهم ولا
في امكانيات ولا معدات ولا حاجه شو اكثر
من هيك بنا نعمل شو اكثر وين نروح انان
لهان لمكان لمكان لدار بنم من ميه
الصبحيات نصحى الصبحيات على ميه على كهرب
على خبز بنلم ورق من الناس عشان نخبز شو
اصر منك نساوي قل لي ايش اكصر منك عمل
املنا الصغار املنا الدنيا امنا اللي
عملنا جبنا الناس عنا ورحنا عند الناس مره
احنا بنيجي عندهم مره بييجوا عندهم وين
الروح وين الروح ايش اسو اقصر من هيك وين
اروح ق وين اروح لقيت انا وين اروح وين
اروح انا عندي 30 نفر في الدار وين اروح
وين اروح هول وين اروح هذول وين اروح هذول
انا عندي 30 نفر في الدار قول لي وين اروح
لقيتها لا في وسع في مدرسه ولا في امن في
شارع ولا امن في ناس واللي جنبي عندهم 40
واللي وراي عندهم 50 واللي قباله انت
بتحكي من حوالي 500 متر في شهداء 500 متر
شهداء ووراي والميه كلها لا تصع الحياه كل
ه البارود اللي انخبط انا لا يصلح للحياه
لا يصلح للحياه وين نروح كل بيت عنده
حكايه وكل واحد عنده روايه الاثنين ميوم
فاحد في غزه كل واحد عنده مواق كل واحد
عنده مواق وروح الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل لنتنياهو مش محقق حاجه لامريكان
وكل هيتنا صامدين وكل هيتنا
قاعدين نشاهد هنا
انتشال شهيد جديد من تحت ركام هذه المنازل
طبعا حتى اللحظه
يتم البحث عن مفقودين في هذا
[موسيقى]
المكان كما شاهدتم مجزره جديده يرتكبها
الاحتلال في مخيم جباليا بحق المواطنين
الابرياء انس الشريف لصالح قناه الجزيره
شمال غزه